la plupart des gars avec qui j'ai travaillé
leur attitude était comme si elle ira bien
vous connaissez Ridley et s'enfuir comme vous
savez ce que vous ne faites pas ce genre de choses
donc c'était drôle mais le meilleur conseil que j'ai reçu
est venu de deux personnes  que je n'ai jamais
été sur un plateau avec ces réalisateurs que Ben
Stiller m'a dit, rappelez-vous simplement que
vous êtes l'acteur principal parce que vous
passerez probablement tout votre temps à travailler
avec les autres acteurs et à en tirer la
performance, mais ne le faites pas  N'oubliez pas
que lorsque vous entrez en post-production,
vous aurez toujours besoin de la colonne vertébrale de
l'histoire, vous devez donc toujours vous concentrer sur l'
obtention de vos trucs, mais l'autre
merveilleux conseil est venu d'Eli
Roth qui réalise des films d'horreur que je
viens de  Je ne peux pas regarder mais je l'aime en tant que gars
, c'est un gars formidable et il m'a dit que ce n'est en
fait pas les 43 ans devant une
caméra, ce ne sont pas les 25 ans à faire
des rôles principaux et des longs métrages, ce
qui va vraiment t'aider  mieux comprendre
ce métier c'est le fait que tu
es papa et t  chapeau est revenu maintes et
maintes fois où vous savez, je veux dire la
chose merveilleuse que vous avez réalisée au
début de la pré-production est que c'est votre
opportunité de rassembler tous
ces grands cœurs et esprits que vous connaissez dans
ce genre d'aventure culturelle que vous connaissez
et  alors j'ai commencé à regarder en arrière dans ma
carrière cette année entière cette
conception de production ou ce créateur de costumes vous savez
cette première publicité qui est des écritures de groupe ou
le superviseur que vous connaissez et ensuite vous passez
par le processus de casting vous
savez mais ce dont vous devez vous souvenir c'est
assez souvent sur les plateaux de tournage vous savez s'il
y a un problème c'est un problème de
communication vous savez et donc vous
allez recevoir 10 000 questions par jour
vous devez répondre à ces questions mais
vous devez y répondre de telle manière  manière
que l'âme créative que vous avez
amenée au travail qui est là pour
servir le récit de la même manière que
vous êtes qu'ils sentent qu'ils
apportent une contribution, vous savez, vous
devez donc créer une énergie autour  d vous que
tout le monde sait qu'ils sont autorisés à être
au mieux